puis deux ans et demi nathalie tellier
est hospitalisé dans ce centre de soins
et de réadaptation après un accident de
la route
jusqu'à présent elle se sentait à
l'écart des activités proposées
c'était des jeux de cartes des jeux d
alors moi avec les mac gé bas je peux
pas je me dis que moi je peux pas jouer
tout seul quoi vous vous senti un petit
peu exclu voilà on va dire et là vous
trouvé votre place
voilà parce que là c'est moi qu'il fait
tout bon même si mauvaise mais je le
fais tout seul dans ce petit groupe des
patients atteints de troubles
neurologiques ou moteur ces séances
d'art thérapie ce sont des moments qui
font sortir du quotidien
ça nous permettait de se libérer
l'esprit en fin de compte entre les
protocoles de soins les rendez vous
médicaux conte avec différentes
personnes de l'établissement
ça au moins ça nous libérer c'était
notre membre chaque patient choisit son
activité en fonction de ses envies
l'essentiel pouvoir s'exprimer c'est un
moyen d'expression artistique
ça permet au patient de pouvoir s'évader
s'exprimer et aussi partager des temps
de convivialité
comment qui s'avère être nécessaire
notamment pendant cette crise sanitaire
les bienfaits sont effectivement sur le
plan pratique parce que l'ensemble du
corps est engagé dans la pratique
artistique
ça peut être la motricité fine grâce au
touché sur la terre dans la façon de
tenir son pinceau son crayon et les
bénéfices sont également dans la
relation
à instaurer avec l'ensemble des patients
sur le temps des séances depuis six mois
l'adapt association pour l'insertion
professionnelle et sociale des personnes
handicapées organise ses ateliers à
raison de deux fois par mois ils sont
financés par la fondation lorenzo
padilla une quarantaine de patients suit
cette activité